3000 a été cancellé 2010 c'est tout un
poème il a pourri mon année c'est la
mort de johnny johnny hallyday ça
restera l'événement médiatique de
l'année mais là je n'ai pu bloquer le
patron du club med à nidau je suis
désolé mon plus beau noël c'est pas bon
tex plié
wendy bouchard fait france 3 c'est un
peu beaucoup de clans de cette année
shy'm sheila shy'm reste assurée j'adore
ce patch and julien courbet c'est que de
la télé sur ces 8 me sentais pas et on
apprend deux choses c'est super
on aura tellement de bons souvenirs aux
bébés mais là faut je me suis déguisé en
goldman à la dame blanche avec la catho
et j'ai dit ok je fais tes pmp mais je
me déguise pas finalement la fois je me
suis le plus marrer quand je me suis
déguisé
ma poule partie et tout mais présent
d'ordre des clients qui changent pas
d'avis rokhaya diallo battu le rebond je
suis dans ma chambre
ludivine la tournée matthieu delormeau
gens ni deux ex-aequo à yakima kelly
fait novelli évidemment et rokhaya
diallo
je crois que les deux sommets
extraordinaires nabil elle est drôle ou
beaucoup moins con que je connais je
dirais sophie davant j'adore son naturel
à dix qu'à penser à la truite par rigole
philippe rythme ils rêvent d'intégrer la
bande de tp
j'adorerais ça me recruter plus personne
habite place
je pense que ce sera mal bentalha dans
le nouveau taxi
je pense qu'il va toucher ça va être
accrue je souhaite que je sois ma compte
voudra dire que la foire la france le
port tenu au mois de juin mais j'espère
qu'il allait taper pour les bleus ce
mois un footballeur coupe du monde soit
vladimir poutine une fan j'ai tant par
la quête tapo absolument que je fasse à
l'âge d'être du poiré perdu quoi perdre
du poids je suis une vache landaise on
plaît qu'une vache espagnole à aa passé
mon permis d'être en bonne santé
commencé à fumer
commencez à voir prendre la tête
mercredi poids mais pas que vraiment
j'ai pu être des vôtres encore en 2018
avec cette folle équipe dtp mt